[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الكرام انا طاهر بركه
احييكم وهذه العربيه 360 حيث الخبر من كل
زواياه ومن جميع جواه
لابارد الالمانيه
كارثه عالميه
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
عشيه اجتماع اوروبي عقوبات على ايران
طهران تهدد اوروبا باستهداف مصالحها في
اسيا
[موسيقى]
بعد احتجاجات صاخبه نتانيا
وسيكون معنا ايضا في العربيه 360
حافظ سعيد المولد العوده ويستمر اللاعب
هذه الكره من جانب العامري طويله خطيره
رونالدو لكن عدت منها في اول ظهور رسمي له
كريستيانو رونالدو يشارك اساسيا في مباراه
النصر امام الاتفاق
حاول
وا بعد المسيرته
الدبابات الى الواجهه من جديد
على معدات الماضي الذي حددت فيه الدبابه
مسار الحرب العالميه الثانيه ونتائجها
بمعركه كورس كانت شهدت وقوع اكبر معركه
دبابات في التاريخ اليوم ومع تغير طبيعه
المعارك في اوكرانيا تجد نفسها امام فرصه
لكسب الحرب عبر الدبابه فقامت وتقوم
بمناسبه دول العالم لكن الطريق ما زال
مغلقا بسبب الخلافات الاوروبيه الامريكيه
هذه الخلافات ليست فقط على اي حال بين
واشنطن وبرلين فالخوف من تورط مباشره
لالمانيا في الصراع مع روسيا وصل الى
البستان الالمانيه لتطالب رئيسه لجنه
الدفاع في البرلمان
باتخاذ موقفا واضحا بخصوص الدعم العسكري
الالماني لاوكرانيا اما رئيس الحزب
الديمقراطي الاجتماعيه الالماني في
البوندستان رولف موتزينيتش فقال ان
الكثيرين من من يطالبون بامداد اوكرانيا
بدبابات ليبارد 2 لن يتوقفوا عن ذلك او
عند ذلك وقريبا سيطالبون بامدادها
بالطائرات وحتى الجنود و سيدفعون المانيا
نحو صراع عسكري
سنستمر في تقديم الدعم لاوكرانيا طالما
كان ذلك الضروريا وبشكل كامل سنبقى بعد
كاروبيين ندافع عن مشروع السلام الاوروبي
ا مشتركا يؤكد ضروره تعزيز القدرات
الدفاعيه الاوروبيه عبر تقويه الجناح
الاوروبيه في حلف الناتو وخلال مؤتمر صحفي
للرئيس الفرنسي مانيوال ماكرون والمستشار
الالماني
اوكرانيا يجب ان لا يعرض امن بلاده للخطر
فيما لم يستبعد ارسال دبابات لوكلار
فرنسيه الى كياف مشيرا الى اتفاق باريس
وبرلين على ملاحقه مجرم الحرب في اوكرانيا
بدوره تعليقا على تزويد كيرف بدبابات اليو
بارد قال ان ارسال الاسلحه يتم بتشاور مع
الحلفاء وياتي البيان في اطار زياره
مستشار الالمانيه الى باريس لمناسبه ذكرى
60 لتوقيعي معاهده المصالحه مع فرنسا
من بين الاسلحه العديده التي تطالب به بها
اوكرانيا برزت دبابه ليو بارت 2 بقوه خلال
الاسابيع الماضيه كمطلب اساسي بالنسبه الى
كياف لكن وصول هذه الدبابه الالمانيه الى
الجيش الاوكراني ربما لم يتم في ظل طماطل
برلين الحلي امتناع الماني تقابله دعوه
غربيه الى التراجع عن القرار وقد وجهت دول
البلطيق لاتفيا استونيا ليتوانيا دعوه
مشتركه الى المانيا لارسال دباباتها
الرئيسيه الى البلاد ما يزيد من الضغط على
برلين وقال ادغار رينكوفيتس وزير خارجيه
لافيا على تويتر
لها موقف قوي بدوره اكد رئيس السياسه
الخارجيه في الاتحاد الاوروبي انه من
الضروري تزويد اوكرانيا بالدبابات وان سبب
التاخير هو مراوغه المانيا برلين وجدت
نفسها اذا تحت الضغط بسبب دبابات اليوبارد
لكنها لا تزال متردده في موقفها السبب
نقلا عن وزير الدفاع الالمانيه الجديد
بوريسبيستوريوس هو التفكير في النتائج
الوخيمه التي قد تنجم عن ارسال الدبابات
تتخوف المانيا فعلا من رد فعل روسيا ومن
امكانيه ان تعد ذلك تصعيدا في الحرب تتسبب
به المانيا مباشره ورغم ازمه الدبابات فان
برلين جددت استعدادها لاستمرار تقديم
الدعم لاوكرانيا السؤال المطروح الان
لماذا هذا الاصرار الاوكرانيا على هذه
الدبابه الدبابه
هناك اسباب مختلفه تجعل من هذه الدبابه
الالمانيه الانسب للجيش الاوكراني في حربه
مع روسيا
دبابه اليوبارد هي الدبابه الاكثر
استخداما وانتشارا بين الدول الاوروبيه
الاعضاء في حلف الناتو ويوجد منها حاليا
اكثر من
2300 دبابه من مختلف الطرز قيد الاستخدام
لدى جيوش هذه الدول ويمكن بسهوله نقلها
برا الى اوكرانيا فهذه الدبابه تستخدم
ذخائر حلف شمال الاطلسيه وبالتالي يمكن
الحصول على هذه الذخائر بكميات مناسبه من
اين من دول الحلف فضلا عن ذلك فان الدبابه
الامريكيه
ما يعني ان اوكرانيا بامكانها الاستعانه
بالولايات المتحده ايضا لتامين ذخيره وهنا
دعوات امريكيه نيابيه
ثاني اقوى دبابه في العالم بعد دبابات
ابرامز الامريكيه بحسب الخبراء العسكريه
لكن دبابه الرمز تحتاج الى وقود طائرات
فيما تحتاج اليوم بارد الى الديزل
لتشغيلها وتقتصد اكثر في مصروف الطاقه
[موسيقى]
وفي ظل الجدل المتوسط حول تسليم دبابات
متطوره الى اوكرانيا من عدمه هددت روسيا
اليوم على لسان النائب رئيس مجلس الامن
بظهور تحالف عسكري جديد من الدول التي
طالطها سياسات واشنطن واتهم بمترمه نائب
رئيس مجلس الامن في الاتحاد الروسي الغرب
بالسعي لاضعاف روسيا او تدميرها معتبرا ان
تخصيص اسلحه ثقيله لاوكرانيا لا يدعو
مجالا للشك في ان اعداء روسيا سيحاولون
ارهاقها او ربما تدميرها
وهذا يدل على ان روسيا تتابع عن كثب
تطورات الدعم الغربيه لاوكرانيا على مستوى
الاسلحه بطبيعه الحال ومن دون شك فان
تاكيد حلفاء اوكرانيا على عزمهم مواصله
ارسال الاسلحه للجيش الاوكراني ما كان الا
ليثير حفيظه موسكو التي ردت بشكل صارم
والرد جاء عن طريق رئيس مجلس الدومه
الروسي فياتشيلا فولودين الذي هدد بالرد
باسلحه اقوى في حال زود الغرب اوكرانيا
باسلحه وشنت بهذا ضربات على الاراضي
الروسيه كما اضف رئيس مجلس الدومه الروسي
ان السياسيين الاجانب الذين يتخذون مثل
هذه القرارات يحتاجون الى فهم ان تزويد
النظام كيف باسلحه هجوميه يمكن ان ينتهي
بكارثه عالميه
مجلس الدومه الروسي وجه اصابع الاتهام
لاعضاء الكونجرس الامريكي ولنواب
الباندستعجل الماني والجمعيه الوطنيه
الفرنسيه والبرلمانات الاوروبيه الاخرى
فكل هذه المؤسسات الحديثه لاوكرانيا يجب
ان تدرك مسؤوليتها تجاه البشريه تقول
موسكو كما وجهت روسيا تحذيرا شديدا لهجه
لكل البلدان الحليفه لاوكرانيا في الحرب
حيث اكد مجلس الدومه ان تفوق تكنولوجيا
الاسلحه الروسيه سينتهي بماساه عالميه
ستدمر البلدان الداعمه لاوكرانيا
روسيا عادت مره اخرى للتلويح بالسلاح
النووي وهي النقطه التي تكررت بشكل واضح
في الفتره الاخيره فجلس الدومه اكد ان
الدول النوويه لم تواجه في السابق حال
التهديد لامن مواطنها وسلامه اراضيها وهو
ما تتعرض له روسيا حاليا في ظل الدعم
المستمر لاوكرانيا باسلحه قد تستخدمها في
مهاجمه العمق الروسي وليس فقط في
المواجهات على الاراضي الاوكرانيه
وبالتالي فان مجلس الدومه يرى ان حجج عدم
جواز استخدام اسلحه الدمار الشامل في
النزاعات لاغيه في ظل التهديد الذي تتعرض
له روسيا كان الكثير من القاده الروسي
البارزين قد ابرز مره اخرى قدرات روسيا
النوويه مشددين على ضروره اخذ ذلك بعين
الاعتبار في الصراع الدائر مع اوكرانيا
معنى من برلين مصطفى العمار عضو مجلس
امناء حزب الاتحاد المسيحي
الديمقراطيه نفهم منكم وجهه نظركم في
الحزب همم كي اين يتفق واين يختلف مع وجهه
نظر السلطه حاليا والمستشار شوت
مساء الخير عزيز عليكم
لجنه الدفاع هي غير متفق مع الخضره ايضا
غير متفقين كمعارضه غير متفقين معه تماما
لانه لا توجد هناك اي ردود واضحه واي
توضيحات لا يعطي كلمه لا ولا يعطي كلمه
همم نعم بخصوص ما بخصوص ما يتعلق
اثنين يعني
يقول لا بشكل واضح لا حاسمه حازمه نهائيا
بموضوع
نحن نريد فقط
اجابه واضحه وكافيه سواء كانت بالقبول او
في الرفض حتى يتم مناقشتها لكن الى الان
لا توجد اي اجابه واضحه من عنده
الى وزير الدفاع الجديد وغيرها من الامور
يعني انتم يمكن ان توافقوا انتم تعارضون
ذلك كاليس كذلك يعني انتم همم بماذا
تريدون ان تناقشوه
نريد فقط ان يكون هناك وضوح نريد ان نعرف
اين نحن متجهين لان الان المانيا الجميع
الحلفاء والشركاء ينظر لها النظره بائسه
للاسف ما حصل في رامز كان هو عباره عن
مسرحيه بائسه هناك تقريبا اتخاذ قرارات
بعزله نحن الان
اصبحكم غير واضح يعني انتم ناطرين وقول له
عم ترموا الكرابي ملعبوا انه يقرر بالاول
وبعدين نشوف اذا ندعم او لا ندعم يعني شو
قراركم انتم في الحزب هل تريدون ارسال
ليوبار تو الى اوكرانيا ام لا
بالتاكيد نريد ارسال
الموضوع تقريبا هو اصبح موضوع حسن لا لا
اوكراني الانتصار بهذه الحرب دون الدفاع
عن وحده سيادتها عندما يتم ارسال اثنين
الى همم اوكرانيا سوف يعطي اشارتين اولا
تقويه الى الدفاع والجيش الدفاع الاقراني
ثاني ايضا رساله
ليس وحدها اذا قامت بولندا وباقي الدول
الاتحاد الاوروبي ترسل تريد ان تغسل
دبابات اليوبارد سبايل التي هي مصنوعه في
المانيا في بايرن فلماذا فلماذا السيد
شورز لا يريد وايضا ولكن لماذا تقحمون
المانيا بمثل هذه الدعوات
وبالنسبه الى البعض قد يكون موقف المستشار
شوز حكيما لماذا اقام المانيا فيما يريده
بعض الغرب في معركه يعني توظف فيها الكثير
من الاسلحه والسياسات الدوليه ضد روسيا
برلين عانت كثيرا من قبل في ظل هذه
الاصطفافات والصراعات
طبعا الجواب جدا واضح الحرب الاوكراني
الحربي على اوروبا نحن تقريبا من الاتحاد
الاوروبي استقبلنا اكثر من 10 مليون لاجل
هناك هنا تحتيه تدمر هناك اباده تحصل في
اوكرانيا واذا تم اسقاط وكران باكمله سوف
تاتي مردوفا بعدها دول البلقان ثم الاتحاد
فقط سيطلق هذا العنان لتدفق الدبابات من
المانيا اعتقد ان المانيا تنتظرنا لاخذ
زمام المبادره هل تتفق اولا ولماذا لا
تطالبون الولايات المتحده اولا بان تفعل
ذلك عوضا عن ان تحمس دول اوروبا لكي تدخل
في كرتون هذا الصراع
سؤال جدا جيد الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
تبعد عن تقريبا 9000 كيلو متر نحن هنا
ابعد عن تقريبا كيلو مترات قليله عن
اوكرانيا فهو ايضا بخصوص الدبابات هناك
نظريتين هيلوجستيكيه ال ال حتى ذكرتها
حضرتك في تغييرك من ناحيه الطاقه من ناحيه
ايضا الذخيره وغيرها وليوبارد موجوده في
المخازن ايضا العسكريه وايضا تدريب القوات
الاوكراني هون هنا من السهل تدريبهم
ويختصر عليهم الزمن في التدريب في
الولايات المتحده وغيرها هنا لدينا ايضا
فرصه لتدريب الجيش لكن هو التاخير هذا
التاخير من قبل الاداره السيد ولا شلونس
تاخر كثيرا كان منذ البدايه دعم اوكراني
واعطاء موقف واضح وصريح هل انت مع دعم
اوكراني او او ليس مع دعم اخرى هنا نقطه
فقط مصلحه المانيا قبل الاوكرانيا او قبل
اي شيء اخر اليس كذلك يعني هناك انت تخشى
على تطورات الامور حاليا كما هي في الواقع
الحالي اكثر من ما تخشى من رده فعل روسيا
لو تورطت برلين اكثر في الصراع وزودت
اوكرانيا باليوبارتو
لا احد كان يريد الحرب حتى السيد حتى وان
كنا لم نختلف معه حتى السيده
الباب مفتوح
واراد ان يكون حوار اراد ان يكون هناك
نهايه الحرب حتى السيد قال له وزير خارج
كل الحروب تنتهي بالاتفاقيات والحلول
والمعاهدات السلام لكن هنا لدينا الان حرب
لدينا هنا شخص لا يفهم لغه الدبلوماسيه
يريد فقط بالقوه على هذه الدول وهو وهنا
كتب السيد
عليه ايضا دعم دعم القوه الاخرىنيه حتى
ايضا باستطاعته تحرير اماكنهم لان هناك
احتمال على اوكرانيا يا اخي يعني انا لا
اعرف لماذا انه بعض الدول تقول انه
المانيا تدخل نفسها في حرب عالميه ثانيه
ما هي الحرب واصله عندنا الحرب الى الان
تقريبا تاثيراتها جدا كبيره على اوروبا
الحرب تقريبا استهدافها الى اوروبا وليس
الى اوكرانيا هناك ايضا ايضا مقوله جدا
جميل انا همم استفدت من هذه المقوله السيد
جون كين اللي كان يقول لا نستطيع للاسف
هذه حقيقه لان استطيع ايضا ضمن السلام
بدون التحضير الى الحرب وهذه الحقيقه الان
تحصل للاسف يعني نظريه محاوله اطفاء
الحريق قبل ان يلتهم دول اخرى ويعني مناطق
اخرى في اوروبا شكرا جزيلا
تحياتي اعذرني انقطع الخط شوي معلش تعيد
شو ذكرت
قلت في حاله
الدبابات سوف لم تذهب الى روسيا ولا موسكو
انه فقط للدفاع عن اوكرانيا لنهايه
الدمارلين تحياتي اليك
[موسيقى]
مازال اصواته المتظاهرين تصدح في مختلف
المدن الايرانيه رغم انحسارها بسبب
الحمالات القمعيه للسلطات الايرانيه مرت
اربعه اشهر على اندلاع التظاهرات ولا يزال
المتظاهرون المصريين على ايصال صوتهم
متحدين كل العقبات التي تواجههم والتهديد
الذي يتربى عقوبات اعدام وحمالات اعتقال
وملاحقات في المستشفيات والكليات وفي
غيرها كلها عقيل واجهت المتظاهرين ولا
تزال حملات القمه التي قامت بها الاجهزه
الامنيه الايرانيه دفعت المتظاهرين الى
تطوير اساليب جديده للتعبير عن مواقفهم
حيث اخذت الاحتجاجات واشكالا جديده
كالاضرابات وكتابه الشعارات لتصلها الى
احراق صور المرشد
وما يعكس الصعوبات التي واجهها المتظاهرون
على امتداد الاشهر الاربعه الماضيه
الارقام التي رصدتها المنظمات الحقوقيه
غير الحكوميه والتي كشفت عن قتل
481 شخصا على الاقل في صفوف المتظاهرين
هذا فضلا عن مواجهه ما لا يقل عن 109
اشخاص عن مواجهتهم عقوبه الاعدام في قضايا
تتعلقوا بالاحتجاجات وفقا لهذه المنظمات
الحقوقيه غير الحكوميه اذن كما تم اعدامه
اربعه اشخاص لحد الان في قضايا لها صله
بالتظاهرات
[موسيقى]
قصه الفتاه الايرانيه مساء مين التي اشعلت
شراره اطول موجه احتجاجه بدات بعد
اعتقالها على يد الشرطه الاخلاق
الماضي
150 مدينه ايرانيه حسب المعارضه على مدار
لاسباب الصحيه
لضربه على الراس
التظاهرات جميلات اضرابات لقطاعات عده
ابرز وقطع النفط في الذكرى الاربعين لوفاه
ماسه ومع المتظاهرون بعنف او الى ديسمبر
الماضي لاحتواء الاحتجاجات صدر قرار بحل
شرطه الاخلاق
جعلته عرضه لسيل من العقوبات سواء من
الاتحاد الاوروبي او من الولايات المتحده
او من غيره مع عقوبات لم تكن مرتبطه فقط
بالاحتجاجات بل ايضا بملفات اخرى من بينها
حبس واعدامه مواطنين اجانب فضلا عن تهمه
تزويد روسيا بطائره مسيره لاستخدامها ضد
اوكرانيا التهديد الاخير الذي يواجه
النظام الايراني هو امكانيه تصنيف الحرس
الثوري منظمه ارهابيه من طرف الاتحاد
الاوروبي
البرلمان الاوروبي فتح الباب امام المقترح
من خلال التصويت بالاجماع على دعوه
الاتحاد الاوروبي لادراجي الحرس الثوري
ضمن القائمه السوداء للمنظمات الارهابيه
والاثنين سيكون حاسما بخصوص هذا المقترح
حيث يعقد يعقد اجتماع لوزراء خارجيه
الاتحاد الاوروبي وذلك في حاله فرض او
لمناقشه فرض حزمه عقوبات جديده على ايران
وتعد دعوه البرلمان الاوروبيه هذه غير
ملزمه للاتحاد الاوروبي علما ان نص
المقترح يدعو الى حضر اي نشاط اقتصادي او
مالي مع الحرس من خلال شركات او مؤسسات قد
تكون مرتبطه به ويبقى المجلس الاوروبي
الوحيد المخول بنت خالي مثل هذه القرارات
او فرض عقوبه
سنعود الى خبر الشرطه الامريكيه بعد ان
ننهي ملف ايران التحركات الاوروبيه لادراج
الحرس الثوري في قائمه المنظمات الارهابيه
اثارت موجه غضب في طهران التي لوحت بورقه
المعامله بالمثل بهذا الخصوص كتب وزير
الخارجيه الايراني امير عبد الله هيان على
تويتر ان مجلس الشورى الايراني يعتزم وضع
اطراف من جيوش الدول الاوروبيه على قائمه
الارهاب وشدد عبد الله هيان على ان الرد
سيكون بالمثل مشيرا الى ان البرلمان
الاوروبي اطلق النار على نفسه بالتصويت ضد
الحرس الثوري وفي رد فعل الايراني اخر على
هذا المقترح حذر رئيس مجلس الشورى
الايراني محمد باقر قريبا باف من انه في
حاله اتخاذ اي اجراءات ضد الحرس الثوري
الايراني فاننا سنعتبر جيوش الدول
الاوروبيه جماعه ارهابيه
نتابع اذا مما افادت به الشرطه الامريكيه
بمقتل 10 اشخاص واصابه 10 اخرين في حادث
اطلاق نار بمدينه
مونيتاري بارك في ولايه كاليفورنيا واكدت
في مقاطعه لوس انجلوس تحديدا وقد اكدت
الشرطه ان المشتبه به في تنفيذ الحادث ما
زال طليقا مشيره الى ان العمليه تمت اثناء
احتفالات بالعام القمري الصيني الجديد في
ما لم تكشف حتى الان الدوافع وراء هذه
العمليه طبعا من المعروف ان الجاليه
اسيويه كبيره همم او من اصول اسيويه همم
تعيش في تلك المنطقه وكانت تحيي راس السنه
القمريه الجديده وحصلت عندما حصلت هذه
العمليه وقد لقي 10 اشخاص حتفهم في اطلاق
النار هذا في لوس انجلوس اذا همم اثناء
الاحتفال بح
لونر نيو يير او السنه القمريه الجديده
الشرطه الامريكيه الان همم تحاصر منطقه
يعتقد بتواجد الفار المشتبه به مطلق النار
ونحن نتبع هذه الصور جميع هذه الصور التي
تريدنا من هناك بعضها يكون مباشره والبعض
الاخر لا يكون مباشره ولكن عموما هذه همم
يعني هذا ملف لا يزال يتكشف بتفاصيله شيئا
فشيئا وهناك ايضا بعد التصريحات التي
تاتينا من الشرطه
التي تعقد مؤتمرات صحفيه لاطلاع الناس في
مونتري بارك في لوس انجلوس على اخر
التطورات
ونحن نتحدث عن 10 قتلى مؤكدين همم اذا همم
عن عدد من الجرحى في اثناء الاحتفال براس
السنه الصينيه همم عندما حصل ده الهجوم
سنعود عندما همم يعني نعرف اي جديد عن هذا
الموضوع هذه الصور قبل قليل اذا وصلتنا
للمكان الذي همم يعني من المفترض انه حصل
في اطلاق النار ومع تبعات ذلك اذا من
محاصره الشرطه
للمكان ومن ملاحقه المجتبه به ومن محاولات
انقاذ الجرحى ونقل جثث القتلى بعد هذه
العمليه المؤسفه اذا التي حصلت هناك
سنحاول ان نعرف المزيد عن هذا الموضوع وعن
همم تطوراته قبل ان نتابع في المعلومات
بتزويدكم في هذه المعلومات نستمع على صوت
الطبيعي
طيب اذا ليس هناك من صوت سيارات الشرطه
الامريكيه
وكل الاطقم الشرطيه المتواجده هناك اذا
واضحه في هذه الصور في موقف كبير للسيارات
في مونتري بارك في لوس انجلوس في
كاليفورنيا بالولايات المتحده الامريكيه
الجديد فور وروده نتابع
في العربيه 360 ايضا
اشتباكات بين القوات الصوماليه وحركه
الشباب في مقديشو والحركه تعلن سيطرتها
على مقر البلديه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد اذا ااه هناك بعض
الاخبار العاجله عن التحالف دعم شرعيه في
اليمن المزاعم الحوثيه بوجود قصف حدودي
على مديريات ايمن به وشدى عاريه عن الصحه
وندعم كافه الجهود لتثبيت الهدنه في اليمن
تلك المنتهيه في اكتوبر الماضي ونمارس
اعلى درجات ضبط النفس في ظل استمرار
خروقات ميليشيات الحوثي اذا اخر الاخبار
العاجله نقلا عن تحالف دعم الشرعيه في
اليمن يقول الان اذا ندعم كافه الجهود
لتثبيت الهدنه ونمارس اعلى درجات ضبط
النفس في ظل الاستمرار خروقات من الاشياء
الحوثي والمتابع ما لدينا اسرائليه الان
هناك لم تمضي اسابيع قليله على تعيينه
رئيسا للوزراء حتى وجد بني امينه ياهو
نفسه في مازق حقيقي وخروجا عن رغبته طره
رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي بنيامين نتنياهو
لاقاله وزير الداخليه والصحه في حكومه
اريا درعي وذلك اذعانا لقرار المحكمه
العليا بابطال تعيينه بسبب ادانته في
قضايا فساد نتنياه لم يتخلى عن اهم حلفائه
حين تعهد بالسعي لاعاده درعيه الى الحكم
بالطرق القانونيه كما اتهم المحكمه
والمعارضه بالتشويش على عمله
اخراج درعا من منصبه سيضعف حكومه نتنياهو
لكونه الشريك الاقوى لنتنياهو في الحكومه
لكن اقاله درع ليست الا عقبه من بين عقبه
اخرى تواجهنا ياهو الذي وجد معارضه قويه
امامه فاصوات عديده تعالى في تظاهرات حاده
نظمت في عده مدن اسرائيليه تمديدا
بالاصلاحات التي دعا اليها وكان نحو مئه
الف اسرائيلي قد خرجوا الى شوارع تل ابيب
وكان معهم رئيس الوزراء السابق يائذ لبيد
لبيد زعيم المعارضه الحاليه شارك اذا
للمره الاولى في تظاهرات من هذا النوع
ونشر لابيد تغريده مرفقه بالصور تظهر
مشاركته في تظاهر التل ابيب قال انها تاتي
لمصلحه الدوله والدفاع عن الديمقراطيه كما
شهد تظاهرات مشاركه وزير الدفاع السابق
نتنياهو وجد نفسه اذا في مواجهه تظاهرات
وصفت بالاكبر في اسرائيل منذ نحو عقدا من
الزمن
وتتواصل الحركه الاحتجاجيه ضد حكومه
نتنياهو حيث ارتفعت دعوات دعوات من
المعارضه الى تصعيدها باضرابات لشل اقتصاد
البلاد هذا وتواصلت لانتقادات لموجهه
للاصلاحات التي اقترحها نتنياهو حيث وصفت
رئيسه المحكمه الدستوريه العليا
التشريعات المقترحه بانها هجوم جامح على
الجهاز القضائي في البلاد مصائب نتنياهو
لم تتوقف عند هذا الحد حيث يواجه ايضا
انتقادات من وزراء الصهيونيه الدينيه
احتجاجا على اخلاق بؤره الاستيطانيه في
الضفه الغربيه في ازمه اخرى تهدد حكومه
نتانيا
مقعد درعي اليمين نتنياهو بقي فارغا مع
بدايه جلسه الحكومه الاسرائيليه لكن درع
اعاده وصل متاخرا وكانه يلمح الى ان
اقالته ليست نهايه المطاف لكنني تنياه
الطره الى توقيع كتابي اقالته من منصبه
وزيرا في الحكومه عملا بقرار القضاء لتدخل
الاقاله حيز التنفيذ الثلاثاء المقبل
ويدرس نتنياهو ان كان ابقاء درعي في
الحكومه الاسرائيليه المصغره بصفه مراقب
وتصب لاغاله الزيت على نار المواجهه
القائمه على خلفيه محاوله الحكومه اضعاف
النظام القضائي ويخضعه لقرارات السياسيه
بين السلطات شعارا لا ينفذ سيجعل جهاز
القضائي راضي يخلي الوزاراته وسياسه
الحكومه بدون قدره على منع وقف خطواتنا
تمسح حقوق المواطنه وبعضها يتعلق بمواضيع
امنيه ايضا الى جانب ازمه درع بدات تصدعات
في اختلاف الحكوميه حيث قاطعوا وزراء
الصهيونيه الدينيه برئاسه مودريتش جلسه
الحكومه احتجاجا على تفكيك باراستيطانيه
فور اقامتها من قبل الجيش الاسرائيلي في
الضفه الغربيه المحتله واكتشاف مودريتش ان
الجيش لا ينصع لامره بعدم التنفيذ رغم انه
وزير في وزاره الدفاع فيما طالب الوزير
المتطرف من فير بهدم تجمع الخان الاحمر
الفلسطيني في اسرع وقت
لن يكون هناك قانون للعرب وقانون لليهود
وعندما يطبق القانون يجب ان يطبق على
الخان الاحمر وعشرات البؤر التي اقامها
العرب القانون هو القانون ولن تكون فيه
هتفرقه
نتنياهو يجتهد في محاوله تهدئه المخاوف
الامريكيين واقناعهم بانه يسيطر على زمال
الامور ولا يترك ذلك لوزاره المتطرفين لكن
ذلك قد يجعل اتمام حكومته ولايتها
القانونيه الكامله موضع شكين حيث يصط
بشركائه الطبيعيين ان اراد ارضاء
الاميركيين او اخرين زياد حلبي العربيه
القدس الغربيه
معنا من حيث يو افاستيرن المحلل السياسي
اهلا بك معنا استاذ يوقف هل
يمكنها ان يتمكن من اعاده درعي كما تعاهد
وبالطرق القانونيه كيف
حاليا يبدو ان ليس هناك الطريق لاعاده
الدرع كوزيرا همم مع تنصيب يعني بموقف
رسمي الى طويله الحكومه ولكن همم نتنياهو
يريد ان يبقي دعي الى جنبه فلهذا السبب
اعتقد انه ينوي دعوه الى
كابينات المجلس الوزاري المصغر للشؤون
الامنيه وربما لجلسات اخرى تخص الحكومه
قديس شخص له هو معني بان حركه ستبقى معه
وهو يعرف انه لا بديل حركه شاص ليس هناك
امكانيه خارجه
يجب على حركه شخص تقبل بهذا الوضع وربما
ستكون هناك اقتراحات لتغيير القانون
لربما العفو من رئيس الدوله والى اخره
اليوم وهو اعرفوا انه شاس ستبقى في حكومه
وبالتالي يتم تسليم الحقيبتين الى وزراء
اخرين من شاس ولكن هل همم التلاف الحكومي
يمكن ان يكون متصدعا بعوامل اخرى حتى لو
بقيت شاس وتمسك بها نتنياهو مثلا همم
موضوع همم
الصهيونيات دينيه اضافه الى احزاب اخرى
تعارض ما يمكن همم ان لا يلجا اليهما او
يلجا اليه في موضوع همم الضفه الغربيه
وما جره هناك هذا يعني في الايام الاخيره
قبل يوم السبت همم امير مختفي للاهتمام
لماذا لانهم كانوا يعتقدون انه بانضمامي
الى الحكومه وباوصول الى صفقه عن نتنياهو
يمكنهم يمكنهم التاثير بشكل كلي على ما
يجري في المناطق الفلسطينيه الوزير
السماطيتش تتفاجا عندما قال للا ترى
المدنيه همم امر بهم الامتناع عن اخلاء
هذه البؤره الاستيطانيه المستوطنه الجديده
ولكنهم تجاهلوا ذلك واستمعوا فقط الى
جالنت وزير الدفاع التي كان منسق مع
نتنياهو مين ما يعني ان نتنياهو ربما هو
اليسار الجديد في
عيونها
اليوم كل ذلك ولكنهم سرحوا بانه اول خطوه
ستكون فقط الامتناع من المشاركه جلسه
الحكومه وهناك خطوات اخرى تاتي وبعد ذلك
سرح بنفي غانم خان الاحمر والى اخره اعتقد
انه في اللي كود لا ينمو الخان الاحمر
اعتقد انه يحدد الحكومه
او لا يبقى الا ذلك
اللعت هو اعتقد لا يصل الى درجه حاليا
تهديد على مستقبل هذه الحكومه ولكن كل
تاكيد
خلاف شديد اللهجه اليوم في هذه الحكومه
واعتقد اننا سنرى المزيد من ذلك ولكن
وربما المزيد من التظاهرات الحاشده
الصاخبه التي لم تحصل منذ عقد من الزمن لا
يهدد ذلك بحديثاته ان استمر حكومه نتنياهو
ان لم يحقق لم يتراجع عن الاقتراحات في
موضوع القضاء ولم يحقق ما يصبونا اليه
نعم التدهورات من جهه ثانيه يعني تحدثنا
حتى الان نواجد داخل الائتلاف ولكن خارج
الائتلاف واصلا خارج خارج خارج البرلمان
هناك تدهورات لا اعتقد انها تصل الى درجه
التهديد على نتنياه ولكن بكل تاكيد ازعاج
مستمر
انه كل نهايه اسبوع كل يوم سبت ستكون هناك
مظاهرات حاليا فقط في المدن الرئيسيه في
اسرائيل ولكن ربما في المستقبل سيكون
تغيير اعتقد انه هذا يزعج نتنياه والدليل
على ذلك انهم
ردود فعل نتنياه والمقربين له بالنسبه
لهذه التظاهرات توضح بشكل كامل انه لا
يرغب فيه فيها اعتقد انه منزعج فيه منها
واعتقد انه هذا يؤثر ربما رويدا من رويدا
على مراته بالنسبه لنظام القضائي في
اسرائيل وبالتالي لن يتمكن من تمرير
اقتراحاته باعتقادك فيما يتعلق بهذه
بالنظام القضاء القضائي وهو ما وصفته
رئيسه المحكمه الدستوريه العليا بانه هجوم
جامح على الجهاز القضائي في البلاد هل
يمكن ان موقع نتنياهو نفسه بطريقه ما في
داخل البرلمان كي يمرر همم في الكنيست كي
يمر ذلك حتى الان هناك اغلبيه واضحه لن
يتنيها 164 وكله مخلصين له حتى هذه اللحظه
ولكن اذا استمرت كل هذه الازمات
والتظاهرات والمشاكل الداخليه في همم
الائتلاف الحاكم ربما الخطوات التي تحدث
عنها عدم التعيييد في سن القوانين
الداخليه لا نعرف ما نعرفه انه نتنياهو
يعرف تماما كيف يواجه كل هذه التحديات
يعني سياسه سياسي مخدرا يعرفوا كل
المناورات الممكنه اعتقد انه هذه
التظاهرات بالاضافه الى ما تقوله ااه
رئيسه المحكمه الاولى بالاضافه الى ما
يقولوا ايضا في الولايات المتحده بالاضافه
الى ما يجري في المنطقه يعني اي توصيل
الاستيطان يكون له رد فعل من الدول
العربيه
معنا بالاكتئاب منها بنهايه المطاف
نتنياهو حاليا
يستطيع ان يجتاز كل هذه العقبات ولكن سؤال
ماذا يجري في المستقبل وماذا يحدث في
المستقبل لا احد يعرف على ذلك شكرا المحل
السياسي من حيفا
[موسيقى]
يوصل جيشنا الاسرائيلي واللبناني عند شريط
الحدود اللبناني بسبب اجتياز جرافه
اسرائيليه بشكل جزئي الخطا الحدودي خلال
اعمال بناء جدا
للتدخل واحتواء الموقف المشتعل لليوم
الثالث على التوالي
[موسيقى]
تحفظت وزيره الخارجيه في حكومه الوحده
في طرابلس على موقف الدول العربيه التي لم
تحضر الاجتماع
مرحبا من وزراء ومندوبين ورؤساء بعثات كما
انني اتحفظ على موقف بعض الدول التي تغيبت
بسبب جهود سلبيه معينه بذلت للاسف منذ
ممارسه ليبيا حقها بترقص مجلس الجامعه
نقرا هذه الجهود السلبيه بانها لا تختم
الاستقرار في بلادي ليبيا استغربنا ابتداء
امانه الجامعه شرطا غير موجود
14 دوله لابد ان تكتب حضورها كتابيا مما
وضع الكثير من الدول في احراج الاصطفاف
وبذلك تكون الجامعه قد اقحمت نفسها في
الانحياز الواضح لاحدى الدول وهو ما
تمنينا تجنبه من امانه الجامعه حرصا على
وحده الصف العربي والعمل العربي المشترك
[موسيقى]
اكد مصدر العربيه ان القوات النظاميه انهت
هجوم حركه الشباب على مبنى بلديه مقاديشو
وقال المصدر الامني وانه تم قتله ثلاثه من
المهاجمين فيما فجر ثلاثه اخرون انفسهم
كانوا يتحصمون داخل المبنى كما ادى تبادل
اطلاق النار او الرصاص بين القوات
الصوماليه وعناصر حركه الشباب الى مقتل
عدد من المدني
في العربيه 360 ايضا في اول ظهور رسمي له
كريستيانو رونالدو يشاركه اساسيا في
مباراه النصر امام الاتفاق المباراه انتهت
منذ قليل وتفاصيلها مع مراسلنا من هناك
بعد الفحص الكون معنا
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد في السعوديه وفي الظهور
الرسميه الاول له لعب النجم البرتغالي
كريستيانو رونالدو اساسيا امام نادي النصر
في المباراه التي جرت مع ضيفه الاتفاق في
مرسول بارك والتي انتهت لصالح النصر بهدف
وحيد دون رد ياتي هذا بعد ظهور اللافت
لرونالدو عندما قاد فريق نجوم الهلال
والنصر امام باريس سان جيرمان فرنسي
الخميس الماضي وسجل هدفين
معنا من الرياض مراسل العربيه عبد المحسن
الحربي اهلا بك عبد المحسن كيف كانت اجواء
هذه المباراه
ومن الذي كان له الفضل بتحقيق هذا النصر
للنصر
نعم الطالب بالفعل طاهر بالفعل كانت
مباراه غير عاديه نتحدث عن انه للبره
الاولى تكون مباراه في الدوري السعودي
منقوله على اكثر من 37 قناه حول العالم من
مختلف القارات متابعه عالميه حضور كبير
جدا ليس فقط من جمهور النصر انما حتى من
الجمهور الخاص بكريستيانو رونالدو الذي
حرص على الحضور حضور هذه المباراه لبعض
منه قدم من قدم من خارج السعوديه خصوصا
لحضور هذه المباراه في الظهور الاول
لكريستيانو رونالدو في الدوري السعودي على
الرغم من ان كريستيانو لاعب مباراه اولى
ولكن كانت في همم كاس موسم الرياض في
نهايه الاسبوع الماضي امام بي اس جي ولكن
هذه المباراه هي مختلفه لانها هي الاولى
والرسميه
لكريستيانو الذي ظهر بصحبه فريق قائدا في
هذه المباراه وساهم بفوز الفريق بهدف
مقابل لا شيء يعني استطلع همم طاهر
والمباراه
للاشخاص الذين المشجعين النصر الذين لم
يحصلوا على تذكره تذاكر نفذت منذ وقت طويل
من المباراه فبالتالي حارس على القدوم الى
هذه الكافيهات في هذه المنطقه في الرياض
لمشاهده المباراه الراحه في كل يوم كيف
شفت كريستيانو في ظهوره الاول وانتم مشجع
نصراوي كريستيانو ضد ظهور يعني ظهور جميل
بغض النظر عندنا ما سجل لكن انا يعني في
الاول والاخير يهمنا كان نصراويين انه
حصولنا على ثلاث نقاط والحفاظ على صداره
همم الدوري الروشه
متفائل بمسيره كريستيانو مع النصر تتكلم
على كريستيانو رونالدو وانت تتكلم قبل
شويه كم اكثر من 36 قناه يعني
تنقل المباراه اليوم طبيعي يكون متفائل
يعني في الاجواء هذه الجميله النصر وصداره
وكريستيانو يعني
ما يعني شعور لا يوصف لدى الجمهور
النصراوي شعور جميل جميل جميل لا استطيع
وصفه يعني بصراحه ننتقل الى احد الجماهير
النصراويه ايضا
واعتقد انك مشجع مخضرم من ايام ماجد
عبدالله
ولم نجد اييه اي بطاقه
فاحنا سعيدين
لان رونالدو في ال
مع المنتخب
مع النصر
هذه اللحظه مشاركه كريستيانو بشكل رسمي مع
النصر تعد من افضل
واهم اللحظات في تاريخ النصر
[موسيقى]
نعم نعم كرستيانو الذي استحقاق قادم مهم
في نهايه الاسبوع امام الاتحاد في النصف
النهائي ان شاء الله
مش سهل اليوم
والحمد لله يعني ثلاثه نقاط ما هي سهله
يعني حتى لو حتى لو ما لعب كريستيانو يعني
اللعيبه يكملوا اللازم اول بطوله ممكن
100% تمام تمام
كرستيانو رونالدو
على الاستحقاق القادم يوم الخميس القادم
امام الاتحاد ومبارك كبيره جدا امام نادي
كبير جدا
[موسيقى]
كشفت تحقيق لجريده الجاردن البريطانيه عن
اختفاء العشرات من الاطفال طالبين لجوء في
بريطانيا
من قبل عصابات اجرام
خلال 18 شهرا الماضيه عاش حوالي 600 طفل
من طالب اللجوء بدون ذويهم في فندق تديره
وزاره الداخليه البريطانيه بمدينه برايتون
تم الابلاغ عن اختفاء 136 منهم
لا يزال اكثر من نصف هؤلاء بما يعادل 79
طفلا في عداد المفقودين
ربما يتم التجاره ببعض الاطفال المفقودين
في اماكن بعيده مثل مانشستر
وزيره الداخليه تقول الامر مروان وفضيحه
حقا على الحكومه البريطانيه الكشف عن عدد
الاطفال الذين اختفوا وما الذي يتم فعله
للعثور عليهم
[موسيقى]
22 من طالبين اللجوء غير المسحوبين بدويهم
فقدوا من الفنادق التي تديرها وزاره
الداخليه البريطانيه
[موسيقى]
في بيان ان وزاره العدل اكتشفت المزيد من
الوثائق السريه اثناء تفتيش منزل الرئيس
منزل الرئيس الامريكي
لعنه الوثائق السريه لا تزال تلاحق الرئيس
الامريكي جوبايدين
عثر عليها هذه المره في منزل بايدين البحث
استمرق الرابط اثني عشر ساعه وشملت كل
اماكن العمل والمعيشه والتخزين في المنزل
لحظه غياب بيض وزوجته اثناء التفتيش
الوثائق الست عود لفتره عضويته في مجلس
الشيوخ واخرى اثناء توليه منصب نائب
الرئيس باراك اوباما تضاف الوثائق الست
الى وثائق اخرى عثر عليها في مقر اقامه
بعيد في الثانيه عشر من الشعر الجاري
ووثائق اخرى عثر عليها في مكتبه السابق في
مركز ابحاث بوشنطن
وثيقه اخرى تدعو الديمقراطيين في موقف لا
يحسدون عليه بعد ان وجهه كثيرا من
الانتقادات الى الرئيس السابق الجمهوري
دونالد ترامب الذي يخضع هو الاخر لتحقيق
قضائي الاحتفاظ باكثر من مئه وثيقه سريه
على الرغم من مغادره واشنطن عام 2021 اما
الرئيس فيقف امام اسئله ملحه تدور حول تلك
الوثائق فحواها ومدى خطورتها عصام عبد
السلام العربيه
[موسيقى]
نذكر بالخبر العاجل الذي ورد قبل قليل عن
مكتب التحقيقات الفيدرالي الامريكي بانه
يفكر في مداهمه منزل
الثاني
والجمهوريون يصعدون الضغط على الاداره اذا
و يتحدثون عن تسستر في القضيه الان اذا
ذلك وفقا لمصادر امريكيه في وزاره العدل
في وزاره العدل يفكرون في طلب الباحث هذا
اي تفاصيل اضافيه فورا ورودها ونتابع من
صوره اليوم في العربيه 360 للمشهد النادر
الذي وثق كيف التقت ثلوج مع شاطئ البحر
ببلديه وزهور في اقصى غرب ولايه سكيكده
بالشرق الجزائري كما اكتسبت عده ولايات
جزائريه حلتها البيضاء بعدما ترشت الثلوج
مرتفعتها
اذا وزيره الخارجيه الالمانيه انا لنبلبوك
تقول الان ان المانيا لن تعارض ارسال
دبابات ليوبارد من قبل بولندا لاوكرانيا
اذا ارتحت ذلك لن تقف في طريقها ولكن
القرار المانيا للارسال لم يتخذ بعد
بطبيعه الحال كما نقشنا في خلال 360 فيديو
اليوم من العربيه 360 هو للروبوت اطلس
الذي من الممكن ان يغير في مفاهيم اكتساب
المهارات وتعديل المسار لتحقيق الاهداف
كما يدفع ايضا حدود الحركه والاستشعار
وساهم ذلك او كذلك في عمليات البحث
والانقاذ المختلفه في المناطق الواعره
والبحريه
[موسيقى]
ولمتابعه المزيد دائما العربيه دوت نت
واخبار الساعه لا تنقطع تتابع بعد قليل مع
اخبار الساعه وصهيب شراير شفت صوره تسكيك
ده وتزهور حنيت للجزائر انا اردت ان نعلق
يعني لفظك للمدن والمناطق الجزائريه صحيح
100% ما السر يا طاهر يا ترى سالتك ههه
طبعا هذا هو تبادل وتلاقي ثقافات طبعا
البلدان العربيه
شكرا لك طبعا المزيد في الصداره دبابات
الالمانيه الحدث اذا كانت ستعطيها
لاوكرانيا ام لا كذلك موضوع الوثائق
السريه الجديده
شكرا لك
[موسيقى]